Moon Knight a new action adventure series
coming to disney plus a very famous marvel
character for many years mark
spector he was a mercenary he
was left for dead in the egyptian
desert and he now may or may not
be infused with powers from khonshu the moon
god or he might just be crazy this is what
disney plus is doing for the mcu it is growing
it is expanding it thank you thank you so much
welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new avengers moon knight video i'll
explain what's going on with the series they've
already released a teaser announcement kevin feige
has already been hyping up the character and how
he's going to fit in the marvel universe so we'll
break it all down of course i'll be doing episode
videos for moon knight when it releases on disney
plus also explain what their plan is for actually
releasing episodes and when we're gonna see those
because we do have wandavision episodes coming up
later this year so if you are new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get everything we're
doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what you want them to do with the moon
knight series just starting with the big stuff
first number five recently marvel announced that
oscar isaac is going to be their moon knight for
marvel phase four he'll debut in the moon knight
disney plus series and based on their production
timeline that'll be released sometime around when
they're getting ready to release doctor strange
to multiverse of madness so maybe we'll see some
easter eggs for him during that because he's a
very dark supernatural based character and they're
also introducing a lot of the supernatural marvel
phase 4 characters through the doctor strange
character we're talking about blade and a lot of
the other stuff that's going to show up during the
moon knight series i'll explain that in a second
because there's a lot of darker characters that
moon knight is going to be crossing over with
but after his disney plus series he's going to
go into the marvel phase 4 movies marvel phase
5 movies and eventually avengers 5 he's a really
cool really weird darker character so marvel's
just using him and characters like blade to push
into the darker parts of the mcu that we haven't
been to before yesterday when the announcement was
made a lot of people were commenting thinking
that oscar isaac had said that he'd never do a
disney plus series so why is he being announced
for this that's actually not true technically
what he said was is that he didn't want to do a
star wars disney plus series for his character
this is the clip of him talking about it it's
actually pretty funny you guys had the opportunity
to continue your character's stories on a disney
plus series would you take it nope i can love you
and you get three million dollars an episode
cashing in my chips he's done his time in the
universe in the galaxy so what he's saying there
is he just doesn't want to continue as the poe
character and you can't blame him for that he
has a fine relationship with disney though he
just doesn't want to do more star wars with poe
disney owns both marvel and star wars so really
he's just walking from one end of the disney lot
to the other anytime really huge or amazing
actors come in for smaller roles in movies
they always try to keep them around for other
projects that they control and he's an amazing
actor so this is a huge win for marvel number
four if you have no idea who moon knight is
and you're just learning about him for the first
time he's kind of like marvel's version of batman
super rich crime fighter detective ultra dark in
tone and certifiably crazy the whole joke about
batman being a crazy person is more of a joke
in the world of comics like the other members
of the justice league dc characters criticize
batman thinking he's crazy wondering if he's
certifiable even a lot of the actors in the batman
movies have played him that way michael keaton
probably the best example as he's coming back
as his version of batman in the newer dc movies
come on let's get nuts make all the moon knight
batman jokes that you want but really the
reference is just surface level moon knight
is fundamentally different in terms of his
powers and abilities he gets all of
his abilities from konchu the moon god
he's also one of the newer people that's shown
that he can wield thor's hammer although because
he's clinically diagnosed schizophrenic that's
what kevin feige was talking about when he said he
could have the powers of kanye the moon god or he
could just be crazy the abilities that he's given
by the god khonshu are basically just enhanced
speed strength endurance regeneration the level of
his power though is affected by the lunar cycle so
at various points he becomes more or less powerful
his very first appearance was in the werewolf by
night comics and originally marvel said that his
powers came from exposure to werewolf blood who
obviously are also based on the lunar cycle but
then they retconned that later and gave him the
khonshu moon god origin story he's a former marine
that gets left for dead in the egyptian desert but
is saved by an idol from the moon god khonshu one
of the earliest gods that was worshipped by the
people of planet earth so he actually goes way
back to avengers 1 million bc there was actually
a recent story called avengers age of khonshu that
i'll explain in a second so moon knight has been
a member of the avengers in the past that's when
i talk about him crossing over into avengers 5
with the other big avengers characters eventually
so part of the fun of the character is not knowing
whether or not he's telling the truth or he's just
acting crazy because there are times when he's
just legitimately acting crazy because he's so
schizophrenic number three talking about more
big avengers crossover recently he was actually
able to steal the powers of all the avengers on
the orders of khonshu the god so talking about
him doing things like wielding thor's hammer
the reason he's able to do that isn't because
he's worthy like captain america it's because uru
the metal that thor's hammer is made from is kind
of like a moon-based ore in the marvel universe
and as the name implies as moon knight's powers
are moon based he's able to control the hammer he
steals the powers of the other avengers using some
special totems it was this really cool big story
where konchu the god got really upset with some of
the other marvel gods and wanted him to go around
and show them up and he got into a big fight with
mephisto so it wound up being a big moon knight
versus the avengers story but you have to remember
the first time that he does wind up crossing
over with other big avengers characters in
say like avengers 5 or the other big marvel movies
it'll be a little more traditional like the first
time you saw in avengers infinity war when iron
man met doctor strange and they had their big
bro off moment because they're both geniuses at
the height of their powers and they both have
towering egos well if we don't do our jobs what
is your job exactly besides making balloon animals
protecting your reality douchebag so you just
have to imagine moon knight having some moments
like that with the other avengers he's also got a
way better sense of humor than most of the other
avengers he's got deadpool level zingers and he's
way more hardcore than most of the rest of them
number two talking about the next couple of years
looking at most of the marvel phase 4 marvel phase
5 movies most of his crossovers seem like they're
going to start out with the more supernatural
based marvel characters so for instance werewolf
by night is also supposed to show up on the moon
knight series there have also been a lot of rumors
that dracula is going to be a character on the
show as well hopefully we'll get this iconic
scene you've probably seen everyone posting it
everywhere so yes of course i think that moonlight
is going to be a big blade movie crossover
character he was also a member of the defenders
and heroes for hire both of the avengers and west
coast avengers teams so for everyone asking about
the marvel and netflix characters like daredevil
iron fist luke cage the punisher as of right now
marvel pretty much has the rights to all those
characters back officially and can do anything
they want to with them charlie cox has been
posting all kinds of funny memes of himself in
the costume this past year like he actually still
has his daredevil costume this was one of them him
just cueing up a daredevil netflix rewatch session
he definitely wants to come back as the character
i know there have been a ton of spider-man 3
daredevil rumors in the past year there are many
many different kinds of rumors about what marvel
is supposedly doing in spider-man 3 cue the
tobey maguire clip you have to remember that
most of those rumors probably won't pan out so
until we see some evidence of say like daredevil
or any of the other characters showing up just
assume that marvel will eventually work them in
talking about the netflix characters but for
instance moon knight and daredevil also pair
really well together because they're ridden
in the same tone gritty crime drama with a
big supernatural bend but i'm really happy with
the oscar isaac casting i think he's a fantastic
actor so i can't wait to see what he does with
the character and if you were wondering yes
oscar isaac is the voice of spider-man 2099 in
spider-man into the spider-verse they did that
amazing post-credit scene with the meme from the
1966 spider-man pointing at himself he's still
going to play spider-man 2099 in spider-man into
the spider-verse 2 in any of those animated movies
that's more of a scheduling thing and if you saw
josh brolin he played thanos as motion capture in
the avengers movies avengers infinity war avengers
in-game and he was also cable in deadpool too ryan
reynolds has been posting more deadpool 3 jokes
like deadpool 3 is practically writing itself
right now there are also some rumors that marvel
is trying to engineer a big crossover deal for
ryan reynolds where they don't do deadpool 3
right away but they do put him in a bunch of
cameos in different movies before deadpool 3. i
think it's one of those situations where they know
they're not going to be able to make deadpool
3 for a while because they have so many other
movies and there's been delays with the virus so
everything is just a couple years out right now
so the way you accomplish that is through a series
of gratuitous cameos which are totally in the
style of something the deadpool would do there'll
be a bunch more big marvel trailers before the end
of the year and my mandalorian season 2 episode 1
video is gonna drop on friday i'll be doing weekly
episode videos for that so make sure you enable
alerts so you don't miss anything everyone click
here for that brand new spider-man 3 sinister six
teaser and click here for my brand new mandalorian
season 2 teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!